vous savez que vous êtes le roi des cons
quoi
[Musique]
vous avez ouvert cette porte
c'est quoi ça
c'est quoi
c'est de la merde
[Musique]
pour avoir un truc comme ça mais de la
voiture là qu'est-ce que vous chantez là
c'est de la merde
c'est pour ça
les fonds
[Musique]
avec une échelle pendant que je ne suis
pas là et maintenant vous voulez me le
vendre non mais alors vraiment
c'est pas cher 10 balles regardez un
beau bouquet comme ça mais il y a pas
que à vous il y a celui-là il est tu
avais pas tout Patou c'est à moi aussi
celui-là mais comment je fais pas vous
mais si c'est c'était merde c'était
direct ça c'était là vous si ça c'est
bon ça c'est à moi alors ça c'est mon
escabeau alors vous foutez quand même
c'est tout partez au niveau de lilas est
parfait d'accord je peux en prendre du
blanc quand même non ça c'est du beau et
ben gardez-le c'est gentil je vous fais
la bise non non
allez allez bisous non allez
scooter ici quoi et comment ça va pas
non
ça craint quand même qu'est-ce qui
craint avec la moto
ça fait 20 ans je suis là il y a
personne qui rentre une moto
vous avez vu ça en train de scooter j'ai
un scooter je le rentre moi j'ai un
scooter je renvoie les gens rentré
si moi je peux pas laisser partir les
clients il faut pas que je les laisse
rentrer c'est ça que je veux dire
à pas travailler parce qu'il faut percer
ici j'ai pas dit qu'il y en avait pour
deux heures il y en a pour facile 15
jours trois semaines
plus aucune mesure rien du tout et moi
j'ai tout pris les mesures mais aucune
mesure pour par rapport à mes clients
non
je ne travaillais non tais-toi
mais est-ce que les gens vont passer
j'ai des personnages et tout je ne peux
pas
une passerelle
vous allez ailleurs c'est une prise
pour brancher le marteau-piqueur
[Musique]
j'en ai plus de gaz je m'en fous de la
canalisation
ça fait caca quand même
avant quand même il fait comme si vous
étiez vous aviez un malaise et puis je
vous fais du bouche-à-bouche
[Musique]
c'est pas grave
tous les jours faut faire une bonne
action
regarde-moi qu'est-ce que je fais je
m'appelle le cul avant des calendriers
faites-le faire caca ici et puis moi je
ramasserai la crotte ça sera ma Béa de
la journée
c'est le trou du cul
désolé
non c'est rien on s'amuse
alors attention
oh là là
c'est bon
attention
je suis désolé j'en ai mis
je suis désolé
oh là là
[Musique]
oh là là c'est plus peur que de mal mais
ça m'a monté directement
c'est le choc
c'est pas moi
oui
combien
1 2 3
tu vois pas
ah bah ouais c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
que j'ai gagné
[Musique]
le ticket
là
elles sont en or maintenant je m'en fous
maintenant
[Rires]
et ben ça c'était une bonne rentrée
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé
oh là là là là là là
il fait un paquet cadeau
que ça fait que Dieu vous bénisse merci
développer cette citation Dieu m'a donné
la foi puis je ne sais quoi c'est la
lumière qui guide mes pas ben oui
on a la foi en Dieu et après ben on a la
lumière ça c'est obligé
mais parfois la lumière elle marche pas
mais c'est pas la lumière du jour c'est
la lumière n'importe que vous soyez que
ça voudrait à une table vous êtes encore
avec Dieu vous êtes toujours avec vous
au grenier dans votre maison partout un
même au grenier
si tu me tutoies je te tutoie
ce n'est pas parce que tu n'as jamais vu
le lion chasser qu'il est végétarien
envie de toi comme jamais envie de
personne c'est un truc de c'est un peu
chaud ça non
ça peut l'être ça dépend comment on le
comprend on comprend si on le comprend
au point de vue physique ou au point de
vue spirituel
il y a aussi le point de vue spirituel
soit à la tête quoi exactement
besoin de toi envie de personne oh
c'était un couple ringard dans les
années
75 80 85 comment il s'appelait
les filles de mon pays là il a oui c'est
court
Enrico Macias
elles sont jolies les filles de mon pays
il faut développer
donc faut parler de la perte de
l'Algérie du regret du pays perdu
oui de tout son passé de toute la
nostalgie que ça évoque
pour imprimer tout le monde dans son
délire ah ouais il se drogue alors il a
rien compris
un peu c'est ça sert pas grand chose
j'aime pas les tricheurs
une ordure une ordure une couille
nous on s'en va avec la dame on va faire
l'amour et puis tu te démerdes
ça part pas ça en plus
vous savez que vous êtes le roi des cons
[Musique]
voilà comme ça c'est bon j'en ai partout
ok l'horreur ça va bien avec votre
t-shirt en même temps
désolé
j'ai rendez-vous en plus
c'est dingue ça
j'en ai partout ou quoi
comment ça s'écrit fuck the police
comme The Police
[Musique]